cela ressemble chaque jour un peu plus
un camp de réfugiés plus assez de place
dans les centres d'hébergement de la
région c'est dans des tentes que
certaines familles viennent se
réchauffer et dormir un peu
je me sens très mal car on a conduit
longtemps avec beaucoup de stress on a
beaucoup pleuré on a dû attendre trois
jours à la frontière
cette famille exténué est arrivé il ya
quelques heures
beaucoup de personnes innocentes souffre
je me sens comme en deuil toutes les 10
minutes environ un bus conduite ici un
cinquantaine d'ukrainiens arrivé à pied
à la frontière à dix kilomètres de là il
trouve ici un café un repas chaud
quelques vêtements et même des jouets
pour les enfants
j'ai sept ans
mais bientôt tu auras huit ans on a
attendu trois jours elle cherche
maintenant une solution pour rejoindre
avec son fils le portugal où ils ont de
la famille
la logistique humanitaire ici ne cesse
de prendre de l'ampleur vous voyez tous
ces sacs de vêtements ce sont des dons
d'habitants de la région et puis
derrière moi des dizaines de volontaires
qui trie toute cette aide humanitaire
ces couches ses produits d'hygiène ces
sacs de nourriture pour l'instant la
situation n'est pas chaotique la plupart
des ukrainiens ne reste ici que quelques
heures quelques jours au maximum avant
d'être acheminés vers d'autres solutions
d'hébergement dans toute la pologne